The ability to pitch an idea or product
well can often mean the difference
between success and failure. My name is
Matt Abrahams and I teach strategic
communication at Stamford Graduate
School of Business. Welcome to this
special Rethinks episode of Think Fast
Talks Smart the podcast. When I first
met famed pitching guru Guy Kawasaki, I
learned so much. That's why I wanted to
bring Guy's advice back for all of you.
And since you provided so much value,
we're sharing the extended version of my
conversation. Enjoy.
Getting to the point is critical in all
communication, but especially
storytelling and pitching. My name is
Matt Abrahams and I teach strategic
communication at Stamford Graduate
[music] School of Business. Welcome to
Think Fast, Talks Smart, the podcast.
Today I'm excited to speak with Guy
Kawasaki. Guy is a renowned author,
speaker, and entrepreneur. He was chief
evangelist for Apple in the [music] late
1980s and early 90s. Currently, Guy
works for Canva, which he co-founded. He
hosts a podcast and has authored many
books, including his latest, remarkable,
nine paths to transform your life and
make a difference. Guy, I had a great
time chatting with you on your
remarkable podcast. Such a fun
conversation. I'm looking forward to our
conversation here. Well, I hope we can
exceed what we did there.
>> Well, thank you so much. Should we get
started?
>> Yes. So, you wear many hats. The one
that intrigues me most is your role as
chief evangelist. You were a chief
evangelist at Apple, currently at Canva.
What does a chief evangelist do? And and
how do you know if you're successful?
So, it comes from a Greek term that
means bringing the good news. That's
evangelism. And so, what an evangelist
does is bring the good news. And so what
is good news? Good news is when you make
the world a better place. With
Macintosh, we made people more creative
and productive. With Canva, where I'm
chief evangelist now, the good news is
that Canva has democratized design so
that people can be a better
communicator. So arguably the chief
evangelist is the chief cheerleader of
the good news. So in that role, you
spend a lot of time thinking about
what's the value that we bring to our
clients and our customers and how do I
champion that. To be honest with you, if
you are really evangelizing a great
product, you don't need to spend a lot
of time thinking about what the value
is. It should be very obvious. If I had
to spend a lot of time thinking about
the value of a Macintosh or a Canva,
that kind of says that maybe it's not
such good news. Good news should be
obvious. I a lot of people tell me
what's it take to be a great evangelist
and I'm tell 90% of it is the product.
One of the things that I know you're
very passionate about had a lot of
thoughts on is storytelling and I'd love
to get your advice and guidance for our
listeners on how best to craft stories
that can be memorable and actually move
people in the direction you want them to
go in.
>> Well, I can tell you like in the last
two years there's been something that
truly has helped storytellers. um two
years ago or 3 years ago, you would have
to have a very broad knowledge of
stories, you constant reading, constant
watching, always on the alert looking
for a good stories. You have to be
really aware that if you're in an
airport and you see somebody throw a bag
down and you know what happens and take
a lot of awareness and I think that
there's this story about how some I
can't remember which hamburger joint did
this but they introduced a third pounder
and they wanted to have more sales
obviously than the quarter pounder but
many people thought that because four is
bigger than three A quarter pounder is
more meat than a third pounder, which
mathematically is wrong. But it's a
great story to use in a speech about
being aware and not assuming that the
audience understands what you're saying.
I mean, there's a lot of lessons in that
story alone. And I think that chat GPT
would have easily given you that story.
Part of a good story is finding content
that resonates and is appropriate. When
you craft stories and you are an expert
storyteller, when you craft a story,
what are the things that you are
thinking about in terms of sequencing
how you start, how you end? What's your
thought process? It starts with the
awareness that you have to entertain
your audience. I think too many people
as speakers, they think, "Oh my god, I
need to inform my audience and I need to
like get my pitch across. I need to get
my story across." You know, my people
are telling me these are the three key
points. And so what happens is you're
working from forward from what you want
to do. I want to get my three ideas
across, my three key selling points
across. And what you have to do is you
have to understand that it's not about
you, it's about them. And if your
audience wants to be entertained, which
is basically every audience, I [snorts]
think if you entertain people, you have
a chance of informing them. But if you
all you're trying to do is inform them
and not entertain them, you're not going
to pull it off. First and foremost, what
I hear you say is that stories are
natural and lean into just the comfort
and natural way in which we tell
stories. And second thinking about your
job is to engage and entertain the
audience and through that you can inform
them and deciding the appropriate level
of information. A lot of lessons in that
has to do with reminding yourself what
your purpose is which is to engage and
entertain and make sure that you just
tell the stories as you normally would.
Conversation much better than formal
presentations. I bet you if we had a
hundred CEOs or CXOs out there and we
said to them, how many of you believe
that the top priority in a presentation
is to entertain? It would be like zero.
Well, just as a personal story on that
front, when I was coming up in the
academic world learning how to be a
teacher, one of my mentors recently
passed away was Phil Zimardo and he
pulled me aside and said, "As a
professor, your job is to transmit
knowledge and information." But the way
you do that is by entertaining. You have
to connect, be relevant and engaging,
and then the students want to learn and
that makes it so much easier. And I
think the same is true in storytelling
and business. I want to switch our gears
here and talk about a form of
storytelling, which is pitching. And I
know you spend a lot of time coaching
people on pitching. What is the advice
you find yourself giving over and over
again about what makes for a good pitch?
The problem with most pitches, it it
starts off with the fundamental idea
that the purpose of a pitch is to get a
check. And so people have this fantasy
that I am going to just use shock and
all. This is going to be Desert Storm 3.
They're going to just be so shocked and
awed. They're going to ask me for wire
transfer instructions. And right there,
you're wrong. And that screws up the
rest of your pitch. Because the purpose
of a pitch is not to get the money. The
purpose of a pitch is to stay in the
game and not get eliminated.
So you, as long as you're not a no, you
still can be a yes. A pitch is a path to
the next step which is due diligence. So
just don't get eliminated. That's
problem number one. Problem number two
is that I think in every entrepreneur's
life they have gone to some panel or
watched some YouTube video where there's
a panel of venture capitalists and some
moderator who says so what do you look
for in a deal and every venture
capitalist says I look for a worldclass
team with a worldclass product in a
worldclass market and then the panelists
they keep going and Yeah, I'm looking
for really great team and we stand by
our team. We believes in our team. We
stick with our team. And so everybody
hears this and they think, "Oh my god,
so I got to convince them that I have a
world-class team." So the CEO stands up
in this pitch and spends 15 minutes
telling his or her life history that my
greatgrandfather came over in the
Mayflower. He landed in Connecticut. He
created this hardware store which became
Ace Hardware and he made a a ton of
money. So he endowed a chair at
Dartmouth and I got into Dartmouth and
from Dartmouth I had a summer intern at
Goldman Sachs and the next year I had an
internship at McKenzie. I came out west
I worked for Google then I worked for
Microsoft I took my net class and like
15 minutes later like what the hell do
you do? Is it hardware software or
whatever? So what I tell people in a
pitch is you got to think there's two
kinds of airplanes. One airplane is a
787 and the other kind of airplane is a
fighter jet. So if you're an SFO and
you're in a 787, you have two miles of
runway and you can just go
and 1.9 miles later you're up in the air
and the miracle has occurred. Guess what
kind of pilot you need to be in a pitch?
You need to be Tom Cruz, right? So in
the first 30 seconds you say my name is
Guy Kawasaki. I'm chief evangel of
Canva. Canvas aid in the business of
democratizing design. We're an online
design server so you can create graphics
faster than you can boot Photoshop.
That's the Tom Cruz explanation. Two
things. One, have the right goal. The
right goal is to just get to the next
step. It's not to get to the check. It's
not to get to the just to get to the
next step. And then second, get there
quickly. It's not about building up all
the credibility and explaining
everything. It's really about what's the
value you bring and get it out quickly.
I think that's great advice, not just
for pitching, but for communication in
general. A lot of people take a long
time. There's a lot of buildup. And I
think that's really important. I also
think, and I I believe you believe this
too, that a lot of pitching is listening
to understand what is needed and what's
important to people. It's not just about
coming in and saying all of this. The
other thing I recommend, I'd like to get
your opinion on is a lot of people
create one pitch and they just deliver
that one pitch across all different
audiences. You have to tailor it. After
you give the pitch about 20 or 30 times,
every time you're going to hear one
different thing and you go back to your
office and then you make that fix. And
after you do this 20 or 30 times, you
take back your presentation and you
start from scratch and you let the the
20 things that you've heard and you've
trying to add. Somebody said, "I want to
know about the patent structure, so you
added a patent page." And somebody said,
"I want to know about the legal
repercussions and trademark
implications." So you put that page in.
And then somebody said, "How are you on
DEI?" So, you put a DI page in it and
pretty soon you've covered every
objection and now you're not Tom Cruz
anymore. Now you are flying a Panama 747
cargo jet. I think that's really an
important point for people to think
about. If you continually build change,
build change, build change, you can end
up with something that's not what you
need. And sometimes it's let's just
start fresh with the input and
information that we had learned and that
helps. I think if you think it's hard to
get a yes in a pitch, I would say it may
be even harder to get a no because the
positive way of saying it, it takes
someone who's very frank and someone who
is willing to confront you. And not
everybody is. And so when people are
asked, "Are there any improvements or
something?" No one except me is going to
say, "You just suck. Just get out of my
sight." They're going to say, "I found
your story about your patent strategy a
little missing." Because they want to
have something to say, something
intelligent as an objection. And then
you're going to hear that, you say, "Oh
[snorts] man, if I only had that patent
thing in a slide, I would have gotten
this deal." So then you go and add the
patent thing and then you're going to
have 20 more objections. You're going to
have 20 more slides. Now you have a 30
slide deck. So what we really need is to
get feedback that's direct. That's so
hard.
>> It is. But if we can find trusted others
or those who can give it to us, it can
make a difference. I want to shift gears
to even be more specific. I know you
have very strong beliefs on slides and
how slides should be designed. You've
actually become very famous for your 10
2030 rule. I'd love for you to share a
little bit about that specific rule. But
in terms of when you think about slides
or things that we add to support our
communication, how should we be thinking
about that to be effective and not
distracting? Being a big David Letterman
fan, I figured out that 10 is about the
magic number. And I I would make the
case that if you think you need more
than 10 slides to convince someone you
have a viable business, that means you
don't have a viable business. Ideally,
you could convince people in one or two
slides. I think the ideal pitch is you
have 10 slides ready to roll, but you
get to the second or third slide and you
say, "Would you like a quick demo and
you start a demo?" And the next 50
minutes you're talking about the demo
and you never get to slide 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 because people are so entranced by
your demo. That's a very good sign. So
that's kind of where I'm coming from
there. So anyway, the 10 2030 rule is
maximum 10 slides. You should be able to
give those 10 slides in 20 minutes. I
mean, there have been like Nobel Prize
winners give 18minute TED talks. I'm
giving you two more minutes than them
because you're not a Nobel Prize winner.
But in 20 minutes, you should be able to
explain anything. And then the 30 points
is because I think people use much too
small a font and they put complete
sentences and whole paragraphs. When you
put a sentence or a paragraph, it's
because you don't know your material
well enough. If you need that much text,
you don't really know your material,
which is your problem. So Nancy Dwarte,
one of my heroes from Dwarte Design, she
has something called the glance test.
And the way the glance test works is you
put up your slide. People glance at the
slide and then they look at you. And if
you put up a slide and there like the
strategic focus of my company is to
enable shareholders to receive a
reasonable return on equity while
enabling employees to self-actualize
their goals for providing a patent
pending curve jumping paradigm shifting
solution to the problems at hand while
killing as few whales as possible. And
now I'm back to the speaker. Steve
Jobs's font size was like 190 points.
You and I, we're not Steve Jobs. So
that's why I'm saying 30. Ah,
interesting. Yeah, it's almost a
huristic. Yeah. The number of words on a
slide implies how how well prepared they
are. So 10, 20, 30. 10 slides, 20
minutes, 30 size font. I often say the
mantra should be what's the least amount
of information I can put on a slide to
add value. Again, it comes back to the
fundamental question. People who put a
lot of text on the slide think it's
because they're going to use shock and
all to get wiring instructions. Again,
that's a false assumption. So, words
versus images. Do you find images,
graphs, charts can be as valuable, more
valuable than just having words, bullet
points? What are your thoughts on that?
>> I believe I agree with that. [snorts]
However, I would say that the danger
here is that like everything else in
pitching, less is more. And some people
think if I put four images up, it's
better than three. Three is better than
two and two is better than one. But you
will flunk the glance test because if
there's four images like dolphin,
there's a picture of a seagull, there's
a picture of Steve Jobs, and there's a
picture of the sunset. Oh, what were you
saying again? I'm going to switch gears.
You also do what I do. You host a
podcast. It's a great podcast. You've
had wonderful guests. What are one or
two things that you have taken away over
all those interviews that you've done in
terms of a learning that you've had or
some insight that you've gained as a
result?
>> I think one of the most if not the most
insight I've gained from my podcast is
from someone who has an office about a
mile from here and her name is Carol
Dwek. So Carol Dwek wrote the book
Mindset and it's all about the growth
mindset. You can have a growth mindset
and believe you can learn new skills and
do new things or you can have a fixed
mindset and believe you can't. And that
was a fundamental book in my life that
you know yeah I want to be on the right
side of that dichotomy. And everybody
who's remarkable has a growth mindset.
There's nobody with a fixed mindset
who's been remarkable.
>> Carol's work is really important because
a lot of people get locked into that
fixed mindset and they limit themselves.
Carol Dwick's work was great as it is.
And then Mary Murphy just put the icing
on the cake because Mary Murphy's
insight is yes, a growth mindset is
primarily in your head. But if you have
a growth mindset in your head, but
you're in an organization that has a
fixed mindset, it ain't going to work.
So you need to have a growth mindset in
a growth mindset organization for it to
be optimal. I think even Carol would say
that was a brilliant insight that added
to her theories. Before we end, I'd like
to ask all my guests three questions.
One I make up just for you and one
similar across all. You ready for that?
>> Fire away. I know you have a passion for
surfing. I'm curious. How do you use
that passion to help you be better at
what you do? I think all of us should
have some kind of physical activity that
we use or have that helps us focus and
channel. I'm curious why surfing and
what does it do for you? Surfing is not
a means to an end. It is the end in
itself. So if you said to somebody, why
do you do CrossFit? They will say I want
to be in fitness. I want to lose weight
or whatever. Um why do I surf? Because I
simply love surfing. It's not a means to
an end. It's the end itself. So that's
number one. And what I love about
surfing, and I started at 60, which is
55 years too late. I started at 60.
Surfing is the most difficult thing I
have ever tried to learn because there
are so many variables. There's the
water, the speed of the wave, the
direction of the wave, the shape of the
wave, the other people in the water, the
reef, the kelp, the wind, the tide, and
it is both anorobic and aerobic. And it
requires great balance. and you're out
in the ocean at dawn and there's like
surfing is the most fun you can have
legally.
>> I appreciate that it's something you're
passionate about and I love that you
took it on later in life. Let me ask you
question number two. Who is a
communicator that you admire and why?
There's nobody you could admire more
than Steve Jobs. I saw him speak several
times or many times actually and he had
such a way of telling a story. Talk
about passing the glance test. You could
look at his slide for half a second and
come back to him. He could really do a
demo. He had a sense of timing and pace
and, you know, he could sense when the
audience, you know, wanted to hear this
or that. He was truly magical. I think
it's kind of like the story that if you
hear that Michael Jordan or Kobe Bryant
always took more free throws than
anybody else on the team, you would say
Kobe and Michael are naturally endowed.
Why did they have to take more practice
shots? I don't know which comes first.
If you're naturally endowed, you
practice more or you practice more so
people think you're naturally endowed.
But addition to the growth mindset,
there's the work of Angela Duckworth,
which is the grit mindset. And I would
say that the flip side of the growth
mindset is the grit mindset because if
you're going to grow, you're going to
face failure. So you need to persevere
in failure, which is grit. Final
question for you, guy. What are the
first three ingredients that go into a
successful communication recipe? I will
tell you that the most important thing
is duh, you have to have something to
say [laughter]
because not everybody has something to
say when they try to create a
communication strategy. So you need to
have something to say. And you know at
an extreme example I talk to a lot of
people and they say I want to write a
book and I say why do you want to write
a book? I said, "Well, I want to
position myself as a thought leader and
a visionary, and I want to build
credibility. I want to increase
consulting. I want to increase speaking.
That's why I want to write a book." You
write your book when you have something
to say,
not because it's going to help position
you. So, I I think that's the number one
thing. That's 95% of the battle. You
have something to say. And I heard you
say earlier that making sure that it's
entertaining and engaging and that it's
relevant to the audience when we were
talking about pitching. You talked about
that and I think but first and foremost
you have to have something important to
say and certainly guy you did you shared
with us many concepts that I think are
really important. Be present for your
audience. Tell the story as naturally as
you can. Make sure that when you use
slides that there's a purpose to those
slides and you're not just throwing a
lot in. And an important point also is
be willing to start fresh, to start new.
And that's a really important lesson I
need to take. Thank you for your time.
My pleasure.
Well, there you have it. Pitch perfect
every time. Thank you for joining us for
this extended Rethinks episode.